بينما تبدو أوكرانيا على أعتاب
هجوم مضاد ضخم ضد
القوات الروسية، فإن الأسلحة التي تبرعت بها الولايات المتحدة
وحلفاؤها تستمر في التدفق على الجزء الأكبر
من الدبابات القتالية الرئيسية الغربية المتجهة إلى
أوكرانيا، هذا النموذج هو الفهد الذي
تبرعت به ألمانيا
والدنمارك.  وهولندا، الأوكرانيون
القدامى ولكن ما زالوا خطرين
يتدربون على الدبابات أخبروني أننا
ضربنا دبابة روسية بهذا الأمر،
يقول القائد إن هذه الدبابة يمكنها
إطلاق النار بشكل جيد من بعيد، كما أن السرعة
والمناورة رائعة أيضًا، حيث تم
القبض على القوات الدنماركية والألمانية التي
تدرب الطاقم الأوكراني على كل شيء.  من
القيادة إلى صيانة Battlefield، لم
يكن لدى الأوكرانيين سوى حوالي ستة أسابيع
ليس فقط لتعلم تشغيل هذه الدبابة ولكن
أيضًا لاستخدامها بشكل فعال كسلاح
وعندما سألناهم ما إذا كان
هذا كافيًا أم لا، قالوا إنه ببساطة
ليس لديهم خيار آخر.
شك في أننا سننتصر في هذه الحرب،
يقول المدفعي إننا كدنا ننتصر في هذه الحرب
بالفعل، ولكي نكون صادقين، فإن
الأوكرانيين لديهم هجوم صعب
أمامهم والكثير من الأراضي التي يجب
استعادتها، ولا يزال الروس يبدون غارقين
في اضطرابات
شركة فاغنر العسكرية الخاصة التي
تقول الآن مرتزقته.  سوف ينسحبون
من باكمد لأنهم لا يحصلون على
الذخيرة التي يحتاجونها من
وزارة الدفاع الروسية
في مقطع فيديو أظهر ما
يقول إنها جثث مرتزقة قتلى
ويلقي باللوم على وزارة الدفاع في
وفاتهم،
وأبلغ
رئيس وزير الدفاع رسميًا  لهيئة الأركان العامة والقائد
الأعلى للقوات المسلحة أن
رفاقي لن يتكبدوا
خسائر غير مبررة عديمة الفائدة في باكمود بدون
ذخيرة، لذلك في 10 مايو 2023،
سننسحب من موسكو أيضًا بعد
الهجوم المزعوم بطائرة بدون طيار على الكرملين يوم
الأربعاء  نائب
وزير الدفاع يقول إن الولايات المتحدة وروسيا
قريبتان من صراع مسلح ويقول
الكرملين إنه يحمل الولايات المتحدة وحلف شمال الأطلسي
المسؤولية عن الحادث الذي
وصفه
وزير الدفاع الياباني السخيف للولايات المتحدة على الرغم من إخباري بأن
تهديدات موسكو لن تردع
التحالف الغربي.
لست قلقًا جدًا بشأن ذلك،
ومن وجهة نظري، ليس له
أي تأثير على دعمنا لأوكرانيا، وسيتم
شحن المزيد من هذه الدبابات قريبًا إلى أوكرانيا، ويقول الألمان إنهم
يأملون في مساعدة كييف على تحويل دفة الأمور
بمجرد عودتها.  القوات مستعدة
للهجوم المضاد طبق الأصل لقناة سي إن إن وسط
ألمانيا